going back to an earlier video you have
to remember that that equal and opposite
angle or or
Force you don't want it to cut through
your your shikaku cuz you're going to
lose your
balance
or what usually happens is you won't
have the power to actually throw someone
because it's a choice between do I keep
applying pressure well if I do that
equal an opposite energy is going to
make me lose my balance so what we tend
to do is start decreasing the throwing
energy and as a result you can't throw
bigger heavier people or resisting
people okay so we want to yes my iido
nagaa has a kind of circularity to it
this is true but I don't necessarily
make these circles with my feet that's
where you get into problems okay so we
know I'm going to
be uh some part of me it's usually the
grounding foot the foot that I'm ground
vectoring all energy on is in the middle
okay not my
Center got it not not I have a foot here
and I have a foot here and then my
spine's in the middle that doesn't work
okay you're double weighted and that
equal and opposite energy is going to
take you off balance so my grounding
foot is in the
center
okay and we know we have some lever of
some kind like usually the the UK's arm
and we know that we want that arm to
move on some sort of curve that's all
true okay and we know from our t-shirt
slogans in iido right you're saying
Center should face what you're doing
that part is true so my center line
should be
oriented with that lever of the arm so
I'm going to draw it a different
color this is just my Center Line
doesn't necessarily it's not necessarily
my hands or my feet or anything no I'm
looking at the lever that I'm moving on
a curve okay
we get into problems where you lose
power especially if you put your your
spine or your Center in the aess access
point and you have two feet out here
you're going to get into problems as you
try to move this lever around because
that equal and opposite energy is going
to cut through your shikaku we already
we already made that video okay but
sometimes people that are stronger than
other
people violate this
Rule and they'll point the center line
over this
way ahead of let's say I'm trying to
move this lever around this circle this
way they'll point it around here and
then they'll pull it into place okay
I'll give you an example of that so the
one we're working with is he's clenching
I was trying to do my ballistics on him
okay but he drove hard and there's a lot
of pressure on that arm
okay so what I'm going to do is pass it
and then take this throw here okay and
we know I'm going to make a circle and
generate some centrifugal energy and
then let him loose okay but a lot of
people will put their Center in the
middle of the axis of rotation where
they separate their feet and now the
center line is ahead of him and now they
pull the
guy okay we don't want to do that that
does not that's not biomechanically
sound so he's
here and as I move him around this
rotation my center line is in alignment
with the lever and we move together and
the grounding foot stays constantly
the grounding
[Music]
foot now because I'm doing
that I don't want
to cross my
legs it looks like I got that Center
Line on him because when I unturn myself
I now
don't and you have to be careful because
a lot of ten con people cross their legs
it it looks like they're
not okay it looks like they're not yeah
you did do you see that you did okay so
on this movement the way that I actually
made the lever go up the circle is not
by me actually making a circle with my
feet my feet don't so I'm going to
ground the axis point that's the inner
foot and then my stand
actually just
moves and here ground and
step not draw the circle with my foot
cuz now I'm
crossed
ground step out pay attention that my
foot comes by the axis point and back
out and the
throwing happens with that 30° that I
have left on the claw not on my hips cuz
I'm going to violate the rule
again so we do from the top boom I shift
my weight onto the grounding foot leg
comes in steps out turn my C that's it
he makes a circle I'm inside a circle
but I don't trace a
circle
again boom
pop different okay all right try it